we are a tag team and perhaps we need to
be because this is a controversial
subject and I come to you as an academic
and I realize that that term has been
used somewhat pejoratively a few times
today but rather than talk about theory
I want to talk about common sense and
start out with what we know and what do
we know well we know that prudent and
sensible banker does not loan someone
nine hundred and seventy thousand
dollars to buy a million-dollar house I
think we can all agree on that we also
know that if that person who's buying
the house says but mr. banker you must
allow me to put down only thirty
thousand since that is the only way I
can get the roee way to return on equity
that I need on my investment we know
that the banker is going to say no what
else do we know I think it was pretty
well rehearsed today we know that in
2007 we had a very highly leveraged very
fragile financial sector it was
basically 30,000 down on a million
dollar house now of course we were told
and we actually assumed perhaps that the
situation was not the same as a highly
leveraged house because banks and others
had accurate risk models and effective
ways to control risk but we also know
what happened so let me ask the question
would the situation have been less dire
had the financial sector been much less
leveraged and I assert to you that that
is basically a rhetorical question it's
not our position that high equity low
leverage solves everything but I think
we can all agree that the situation
would have played out very differently
and in fact this was what was alluded to
before we can look back in history and
we can see times when the bank sector
was much less highly leveraged much more
equity and things still seem to function
which leads to the question why don't we
have more equity and we've talked in
various ways today about some of the
advantages of having much greater equity
bigger down payments you might say
systemic risk is certainly reduced
there's less chance of a financial
crisis and the deadweight losses and we
never should forget the deadweight
losses that are associated with the
financial crisis which David Myles
quantified in various ways here risk is
privatized we talked about the
importance of having the market
basically governing how things are done
rather than leaving it to regulators
well to the extent that insurance is
being provided here it's by equity not
by the government and so we can say that
this is moving in the direction that
Kevin Walsh and others were saying of
having the market do it rather than the
government and the incentives to take
socially unproductive risks are clearly
reduced at the margin if we increase
equity so the social benefits are quite
large which of course leads to the
question why is there a controversy here
why are we up here because if equity has
so much to offer in terms of these
social benefits why don't we see more
people calling for it why is there such
resistance and of course the resistance
is that it's expensive
is it really expensive that's the
question we want to ask and it's very
very very important I put three berries
in there to distinguish between private
and social and we've sort of talked
around the margins on this but let's be
very clear what are the private cost to
have more equity well the tax code
basically disfavors equity favors debt
financing there's no doubt about that
the government makes debt cheap through
implicit guarantees the too-big-to-fail
subsidies perhaps under priced deposit
insurance various things of that sort
that favors debt over equity and
increasing equity
we'll see a little bit later when Peter
talks mechanically reduces roee and also
reduces risk but if compensation is
somehow tied somewhat rigidly to our OE
this potentially can reduce someone's
pay which gets certain people's
attention what is the social cost that's
the real question here and that's a big
question mark let's talk about a little
bit more about these incentives there's
the too-big-to-fail
subsidy that we've talked about and if a
bank believes if the investors in a bank
because pacifically the creditors
believe that there's some potential for
the government to come in and give
support that's going to lower the
required yield on that debt and you can
do a very simple calculation to show
that this is a non-trivial effect for
instance if we just reduced the average
cost of liabilities by 2.5 basis points
with only three percent equity that's a
one percent increase in ROA if we
increase or decrease that cost by ten
basis points again that's not all that
much we get a three percent increase in
our OE so this definitely creates some
incentives now is this hypothetical is
this academic theory no even Moody's as
we talked earlier recognizes this and in
fact gives two different ratings one
based upon government support and one is
a standalone so let's talk about the
incentives and banking very quickly I'm
going to simplify banking a little bit
here but not much it's a spread business
you receive interest and then you pay
interest but bankers if they get this
subsidy aren't really paying all the
interest that they should some of that
subsidy is basically given by the
government that comes in the form of
less interest paid and that's a minus to
all of us in the room that aren't
bankers and then of course we pay taxes
all of us including the banks but that's
a benefit to the government there is a
question as to what's done with it now
we divide this by equity we get required
rate of return on equity or the return
on equity here and now let's look at
what the incentives are
but I take that equity and make it
smaller what happens well the first
thing is I will pay a little bit more
interest but that's increasing the
subsidy and I'll pay less taxes so the
bank is going to have a higher numerator
here the government has clearly lost its
- the subsidies plus the taxes both of
those have gone down and now we're
dividing by a smaller number there on
the numeron in the denominator that's
going to make for a higher ROA
so the incentives are very clear but let
me also be very clear just because
bankers have an incentive to argue for
economizing on equity for the very clear
reasons that we just saw it doesn't mean
that they're wrong when they say that
equity might be expensive but it does
mean very strongly that we should be
skeptical and we should demand that they
support their claims with sound
arguments now one thing that might be
asserted is yes there are these
subsidies but these subsidies are
important because they do beneficial
things and they pass on some of these
subsidies to those who are borrowing
let's think about that just a little bit
more if we are basically giving tax and
implicit government subsidies that are
creating incentive for leverage and high
leverage that's bad because that creates
the systemic risk that we're all trying
to avoid and the question really is at
the end of the day does that really lead
to better loans and if it does let's do
it directly not through a mechanism that
creates problems so the big question
here which we're going to look at it in
a little bit more detail here is are
there social costs to bank equity now we
started out looking at private costs but
no that's not what we should look at we
should look at the social cost and be
mindful of the social benefits that are
very large and now there's a question as
to what the social costs are so what
we're going to now do is turn to a very
skeptical appraisal of the arguments
that have been put forward for saying
that that question mark there is
positive and large
I've made it small but I don't want to
prejudge things here's Peter thanks Paul
and look forward here into the
background so obviously we're thinking
about today the the trade-off between
capital requirements which we have many
of our you today are will reduce the
probability of financial crisis on the
other hand there's the issue of higher
borrowing potential higher borrowing
costs and if that will slow economic
growth and so the real question is how
do we trade those off
we've seen some analyses today heard
some discussion about it and what we're
trying to do in our discussion is we
find that debate and and get us to focus
on what the key issues are obviously
we've heard a lot today about the
increase in leverage that led to the
financial crisis and we think about sort
of these deleveraging spirals that
result from leverage if we have three
percent equity of one percent decline in
asset value means a 30 percent reduction
contraction balance potential balance
t-shi contraction if we try to
recapitalize without raising new funds
and so we get the problem of asset fire
sales in liquidity market failure
uncertainty bailouts all the things that
we observed in the crisis and so the
question is can we address that with
more capital is is that a tool that
regulators should feel confident
utilizing in this context and we going
back to David Vinny ARS point this
morning where he argued that liquidity
is costly maintained but even more
costly if not maintained I would say the
same is true for capital in terms of the
benefit of maintaining capital is quite
high and probably even higher given
capital adequacy insolvency is a
precursor to liquidity and yet I'll
argue
costs are actually lower for maintaining
adequate capital than for liquidity per
se where we know there is some cost to
maintaining liquidity for capital argues
is very different that's an important
point that we think we'd like regulators
to understand in terms of being more
flexible in their use of capital as a
mechanism to increase safety in the
banking sector so so the question is
equity to expensive and what I want to
talk about it Mike in my section is sort
of what are some of the arguments that
have been used that you hear about why I
can expensive why we don't think those
are the right arguments and why our kind
of question to practitioners who are
concerned about these requirements is
you know what let's get let's dig deeper
into what might be the real cost because
the ones that are put forth don't seem
like the Krait the correct one so first
confusion sort of crowding out concern
via that increased capital requirements
will force banks to reduce lending
simply because it means they have to set
aside some assets and of course that's
not what capital requirements are about
it's not about setting aside any assets
that the funding issue and it's about
leverage it's really a question of
capital structure so the idea that
holding capital is expensive as sort of
a misnomer since we're not holding
anything per se it's not it's not a
question about how we allocate assets in
terms of increasing capital there are
different ways we can do that but
importantly there's no mechanical
requirement that we reduce lending
through increased capital requirements
of course that's one way it can happen
if I want to double the amount of
capital the bank has one way to do it is
to contract the assets and move from
Temper state capital 20 percent capital
in that way but an alternative way to do
that is we could simply recapitalize
some of the liabilities
through an increase in equity and we
might argue what we don't necessarily
like deposits are important for the
value creation of the banking system and
in services it provides well there's
still a third way we can do it which is
an asset expansion right we could simply
raise new equity put new assets on the
balance sheet a third way to do that and
so just there's no mechanical reason
sometimes argued that an increase in
equity requirements are going to lead to
a reduction in lending now of course we
would say well it's about the cost of
these three different alternatives and
there is some reason to think that banks
might be pushed towards the former
versus the latter in terms of raising
new equity will benefit creditors and
will help creditors and and therefore be
costly to equity holders and so one of
the things from a regulatory standpoint
to think about is you know are there
ways we can provide mechanisms that push
banks in this direction versus this
direction of course helping creditors is
a way of attempting to get banks to pay
for the costs of the risks they're
taking as opposed to leaving it for the
government for government bailouts and
other subsidies from that form so so
that's one thing to think about and one
of the proposed along these lines is to
suggest that we get banks to increase
capital by looking at lagged asset base
as opposed to allowing them to do it by
asset contraction but certainly
something to think about but the key
point is there's no mechanical need for
an increase in capital to lead to a
reduction in lending the second point is
lower our OE which we heard discuss this
morning that is a concern that you'll
hear from the banks that it's going to
lower the returns to equity holders and
you know that statement is partially
true but the point is that lower re does
not reduce firm value doesn't
necessarily reduce firm value and that
lower expected re is the
appropriate given the reduced risk with
higher capital requirements and in
particular if we just look at what
happens to our re comparing a 10 percent
capital with 20 percent capital it's
true that our we is lower in good times
with higher capital but it's higher in
bad times right that capital is
providing that buffer in bad times and
so what we're sort of giving up in a
sense up here for shareholders were
gaining down here and that if things are
fairly priced and ignoring other
imperfections in the market these two
should be equivalent in value terms from
a shared respect perspective and so it
doesn't it doesn't reduce shareholder
value per se now of course if the
downside here is already being if equity
holders are not I don't need to worry
about that downside because of other
protections through government
guarantees than they are giving up
subsidies again in this trade off and
that would be an example of a private
incentive not to want to increase
capital and we spoke of earlier
performance evaluation another issue
obviously you know we think about ROA
and I want to give another example of
why re isn't really a very good measure
to think about the value created by the
banks we think of a manager a fund
manager with a 22 percent return or one
with a 20 percent return and who
deserves higher compensation well
obviously it's not enough information
especially if I told you that the first
one was taking a much riskier strategy
and had much fewer assets under
management the point is that when we
think about returns we really need to
think about risk adjusted value added so
the Alpha generated times the assets
under management or kind of translate in
the banking context we want to think
about excess roee above what's a fair at
risk adjusted return given the risks
they're taking times the amount of
equity base that's that's on and that
measure is going to be invariant to
leverage again absent other frictions
and so forth so looking at our lower you
per se isn't really the right measure
from want to think about value added the
third point on equity is expensive is
simply that you know
well equity is just equity capitals much
more costly so if we got to increase the
amount of equity capital that's going to
raise the costs of doing business and
that's going to be trans transferred to
borrowers we heard this morning that the
cost of equity is a step function or or
might not move as we as we increase
capital and really as arguments ignore
the fact that we know the class of
equity will decline with higher capital
reduce risk offsetting a tire cost
there's a fair amount of evidence for
that empirical evidence it's also the
basis of most models that the banks
themselves use when thinking about a
variety of products that they go ahead
and market so so that's got to be the
case and so we really have to be arguing
something about equity investors being
irrational there being some other supply
constraints or other factors in the
market so I want to kind of just do a
simple thought experiment here you know
we've got assets and liabilities we
think of the asset side as sort of value
creation
unlike most standard industrial firms
though valuation also happens on the on
the liability side for banks in terms of
deposits deposit taking and transaction
services and so forth so we want to
think of some of this as part of the
underlying business of the bank but
there's a fair amount that's just of the
funding piece and I want to think about
what happens if we if we separate some
of that and we take some of that funding
in and replace it rather than so being
highly leveraged to put equity in its
place and the point of course is that an
irrational market the cost of this
larger equity piece should be the
blended cost of the debt inequity that
we had before this would be again just
standard argument with you making any
sort of portfolio analysis and therefore
that it shouldn't raise the weighted
average cost of capital for equity for
the bank that shareholders should
understand this if they don't then
something is must be fundamentally wrong
in the market again either there's some
irrationality or supply constraints or
other factors now if you like one thing
you could think about is
suppose we did that and suppose we were
concerned that this cost of equity
reduction would not occur one could
think about separating the leverage kind
of from the bank entity itself so we
could imagine taking this equity pooling
it and then creating products that
replicate these payoffs that could be
sold to investors but separate from the
bank activity itself so even if there
are ultimately losses on some of these
products equity link type products they
don't put the bank in any sort of
distress so we could imagine separating
those and the real question is what is
the cost from doing this in fact this
might be even more flexible in terms of
if investors prefer more leverage or
less leverage we could get the optimal
mix determined separately from the
bank's activity itself okay so that's
let me leave it there and turn over to
and not I think the key questions are
we've talked about taxes and government
guarantees as private benefits to the
banking sector but not social benefits
we talked about some of the key
arguments that you hear for why equity
is costly and said that they don't
really hold up so the key question I
think for practitioners and for
researchers think about well if there
are costs from what are they and let's
get down and define them precisely so we
can measure them and so we can make sure
whatever policy prescriptions we have
our directed towards what those true
costs are so I'll just go into here so
the key question that we have here is
high leverage somehow a function is
something inherent in banking this comes
with the territory of banking and got to
be there because that's the way it is
it's that business it's a business it's
a leverage business our answer to this
question is that we've looked at all of
the arguments that were made and
actually some that are not yet in our
paper that are also made and so far in
about a year or more looking at it we
actually have not found anything that
would convince us that high leverage is
necessary
for tanks to function it is true that
some debt of the bankers was mentioned
it's part of their business but that is
not the same the amount of that is not
the same as the amount of leverage so it
integral our social costs and we do not
see any benefit from the high leverage
solely everything about the value that
banks create can be done with less
leverage there is absolutely nothing we
can see in the economics of it that
would tell you that 25 percent equity on
total balance sheet should be
unthinkable for banks if somebody thinks
that that is a terrible horrible thing
we haven't explained we haven't seen why
yes
in particular this balance sheet see if
you ought to think about it and I do not
mean to suggest that banks should grow
even larger this is just a way to think
about this because I think once they
have more equity funding we will see the
natural size of the banking sector and
of individual banks more organically is
whether adding equity is somehow
expensive and in what sense is it
expensive in fact I would argue we argue
that it's not only not expensive it's a
social bargain only good things happen
when you do that for a while anyway in
other words as far as the eye can see
from where we are right now all we can
see is benefits to increasing equity we
don't see costs certainly not high cost
so we didn't say that equity is not
costly we said it's not expensive
expensive it's in Tiffany's you know
expensive so you could say that we need
the safety net expansion and I think we
already agreed in this form that that is
not a good thing the safety net was
created to prevent inefficient bank runs
in FDIC before that by the way banks had
in the u.s. not even limited liability
so banks in the US until the 1930s 40s
in many states I had double triple and
unlimited liability and the liabilities
of the downside of the
no at the time was worn by equity except
that in depression there was a lot of
personal bankruptcy no was decided there
was a lot inefficient runs and when
banks were very small and not
diversified they were around even though
there was a lot of equity so it's not
like they were run for different reasons
and so we've got a betting system and
the system has become more leveraged as
we saw but the safety net has expanded
as the Bank of Richmond is shown and the
question is whether whether we have sort
of too much of it so to expand it
without giving a free gift to the bank's
is to charge for it which would mean
some kind of a bailout funds but that's
very very difficult to price and already
FTSE is hard enough to price so it's not
if we can avoid it that's not the way to
just ensure everything it would be very
hard and is the moral hazard is always
there because it always be ahead of
trying to take advantage of those
guarantees so we do not recommend that
if it's possible to create a little more
self insurance and self insurance is
precisely equity equity means that the
private sector bears a lot more of the
downside and so it's a question of
whether they economy the whole can send
us can stand to have 20% of risk capital
in the economy back up the bank's
liability instead of some other system
we had a presentation about a loss
absorbing debt and this is sometimes
people think of contingent capital and
bail enabled debt and the substitute for
equity we believe that it's a for
substitute in the crisis no hybrids
suffered any losses the idea here is to
conserve on equity and since we do not
believe equities extensive we do not see
a reason to conserve on equity and
create magical complicated ways to get
the debt to become equity because then
we have to ask what why it was that in
the first place which is like long-term
debt or others why was it issued as that
to begin with what was it doing as a
debt because it's not they secure that
it's not the deposits that are going to
be inflicted that they're its unsecured
subordinated debt why is it there
instead of being equity so I'm going to
ask that question
beylin is of course a sort of can be
thought of it's part of resolution and
as a way to sort of sort of preempt the
bankruptcy the laws of bankruptcy what
happens when you default and obviously
we want a better system then then
bankruptcy laws are complete agree with
that and in that context obviously we
should we should be thinking about
whatever we can do across countries and
all these things but it is not a
substitute for pushing equity
requirements way higher and we would
even say way higher than David Myers
recommends and so why bankers agree for
to koco's well Barclays told us that
they want Coco's
so that they re will not be affected
that is not a valid reason taking
advantage of taxes tax subsidies to the
extent in this exedoc the world is also
not as social causes we explain so what
we feel is that if you compare if
whatever you were going to make
contingent capital at the time that you
issue it is contingent capital you
instead make it equity then when the
assets go down obviously we don't want
bailouts so none of the none of us kind
of want that if contingent capital was
going to bring you the equity that you
need if it was issued as equity you
would also have it there so it's not
about recapitalisation it's about
capitalisation so whatever
contingent cover was going to do for you
equity can do for you and somebody's
going to have to explain why contingent
capital then is not better than that but
why it's better than equity there are
other things that are said some of them
are academics they're not logical
policies or this is confusions between
private and social costs and benefits
but we have theories that say that debt
contracts are have discipline
well discipline as we already heard does
not work when there's a bailouts
so anything that guaranteed is not going
to do any discipline for you we can
agree on that
the threat to run is not going to
discipline when it's not a credible
threat the threat to default it doesn't
do anything if
if there's a bailout or or if you can
recapitalize immediately so it there
needs to be a real threat there and it's
not there and the question also is even
if you were to say that that can
discipline and that does discipline in
many models which explains why the bank
itself does not take equity position in
the small businesses that it once so
that is an optimal contract for you know
pay me and then I want it to worry about
it until you don't pay me and then I
will worry about it it cost okay so
that's kind of optimal contracting for
small people
Berbers but not for the banks
necessarily even if it was providing
some discipline the question is it do we
need it at the cost that the social cost
is it is involves can we do governance
and how do other companies in economy do
their governance when they have 8090 a
hard person equity how do they actually
discipline their managers do they need
high leverage and if they don't if they
choose not to then how do they do it and
can banks also do it can they get a
better contract with their managers can
they give their managers preferred can
they do anything that would not create
this cost on the economy so then people
talk about issuance costs here there are
two parts to it one is this sort of what
in and we have a buzzword for it's
called Meijer imagine if it's an
issuance cost about the stigma
associated with with issuing equity or
withholding dividends and yes but that
is not a reason to not move from the
level of capital that we have now to
another level that is more of a
transition thing but once you're there
any friction of the sort you have is
actually lower so whatever whatever you
talk about being at 5% versus being a
20% equity is better even on that front
because you have left me to raise equity
so you're not in the market as much
because you ever attained earnings to
view and this stigma also is not a
social cost and can be may help by
removing discussion which was already
mentioned here so that there is no
stigma just like tarp was given to banks
in a sitting in a room and not allowed
to to spook anybody
by taking or not taking the money the
big picture if you want look at the big
picture is it sort of the big picture of
balance sheet see and if the big picture
says when people ask where is all this
equity going to come from
well equity comes from end investors in
the end for the entire economy so if you
look at the big picture here then what
we have in one case of highly leveraged
banks is we have three kinds of assets
some assets are held directly that's
Class B oh what did I do here what am I
supposed to press to get this that's
been all this anyway in I'm still not
bidding oh this one haha
so in here we have a Lionel average Bank
or banking system and some of the assets
in the economy are held through that
some are held directly some are held
through other intermediaries now if I
move to my balance sheet see so I didn't
touch whatever the bank is doing I
didn't touch all the loans that are
wonderful and I didn't touch all the
deposits that everybody needs for
liquidity oh and other things that are
there I didn't touch I just did my
balance sheet see just for this sake of
showing you that I don't need to touch
anything in the economy I'm only
regrouping claims in the economy so in
this balance sheet right in this picture
right here a B and C are still there and
I don't even mind if the banks have more
assets in the economy let them buy more
stuff and backup their liabilities it
aligns incentives better when that
happens so even if you were to tell me
if you already clean I don't believe
that they will grow this way
but I would even say I don't care if
they're going on visits with equity then
nothing really productive change in the
economy and because an investor still
hold everything that they held before it
is the case though that if if the
government was going to bail out the
these banks then it's not bailing as
much out these banks over here but we
think there's capacity to move to there
okay
so basically marketing has more has
benefits because highly leveraged firms
in general but especially highly
leveraged firm that have implicit
guaranteed
I have incentive to take excessive risks
this is a problem that basically makes
firms stay away from from high leverage
because that will recognize that they
will end up taking excessive person will
require return for that or really
require a lot of coven covenants to
protect from that so that in normal
companies is going to become a little
honor a little onerous on the on the
firm which why many firms don't want to
lever but the bank debt holders do not
impose such covenants and other things
the big other issue hanging here is that
overhang and this is the reason actually
the banks are really reluctant or unable
to raise funds or unwilling to raise
fund for new loans when they're only had
highly leveraged so when you have a lot
of that already in place you are
impaired in functioning and that is a
reason that we had a credit freeze the
reason for credit reduction is not too
much equity it's too much debt and I
will talk some more about lending if I
have the time
we are never playing field ever and
op-ed with one of my co-authors about
this so one has to think about who's
backing up as long as there are no
subsidies it's good to have competition
the unregulated shadows is basically not
an argument for anything because we had
shadow banking with the low capital
requirements so if we want to throw our
hands in the air and say we can't
enforce anything then we might as well
no tax because of tax loopholes in other
words that's just and the fittest
arguments can you or can't you regulate
is the question to that that there would
be enforcement issues is clear with any
regulation and they were they
enforcement issues before so it's not
like this problem is gonna be new or
necessarily worse because it's always
going to be there it's the same problem
with low and high capital requirements
you need to figure out how to do it and
so so they said it's it's kind of not
it's an enforcement issue and it is a
challenge to enforce it
regulations but we just have to figure
out what we want to do and then we have
to try to challenge it will there be
might there be actual ending with
contraction if you really think about
this question there is first of all the
possibility just the possibility that it
actually is not true these big law these
great loans are going to lie there and
not being taken well in New York these
days it was if micro lenders that lend
because banks kind of don't feel like
it's too much work to check credit rates
worthiness it seems but in the option
expensing debate we heard that the
economy would shrink and that didn't
happen when options became expensed so
just because people say something
doesn't necessarily make you feel bad if
you think about what the credit will go
down well maybe some credit should go
down we think we're the credit bubble
and we think there's too much lending so
not all lending is good lending we want
good lending not just any lensing okay
so if some lending doesn't happen there
might be just as well we don't know what
the true economic cost should be the
risk weights give it distorted
incentives this is was discussed at
lunchtime and Marta McArthur is very
strong it strongly disillusioned with
risk weights so Rafael presented the
view the risk weights could be distorted
in one of the immediate ways to satisfy
cap requirements based on risk weighted
assets is to move to a low risk weighted
assets I would only point out about risk
weights that Greek sovereign debt has
zero risk weight and face 20% right now
and that sort of rests the case in trip
related securities also has zero risk
weights and turn out to be quite
systemic so risk weights do not give you
a measure and we already has that
covered the debt overhang itself where
we are right now would make you not lend
and so that by itself is a is all
because they're already in a bad place
and not because of where we want to go
what we want to go is to be in a place
where there won't be as much of that if
planning spread should increase maybe
because of the subsidies that are
removed and there will be some a little
bit of a margin there but we'll it
depends what we want to subsidize do we
want to subsidize lending or do we want
to subsidize subsidized the leverage of
the banks so they can pass it on somehow
it's a very inefficient way so the
summary is that we do not have numbers
ok people process on the numbers because
we don't have begin to have an economic
theory of the costs where we are right
now
so David presented some costs we can
argue even with David on exactly what
those costs are but I we look at through
at the rate and I have 30 percent we
just don't see where the costs come in I
don't see the big as David pointed out
miles there is it's not clear into that
sensitive once you get to so it's not
going to be a decimal point because I
cannot even quantify some of these other
benefits that I see and the costs I can
barely find so it's going to be very
hard to make them kind of on the same
scale from where we are right now or
even from Basel requirements should not
be one number I want to mention that
because the you know the best line on
this is that the Charles a good hard
line on the taxicab in the station so if
you have a regulation that says that
there should be a taxicab waiting at the
train station at all times then when you
get to the train station at 2:00 in the
morning the taxi cab cannot take you
because then there won't be at execute
in the train station so the capital
requirements cannot be one number and we
see what that happens when people just
just reveal leverage to a number we need
to draw down on it you must have a range
so they the buffer in Basel in principle
is a big breakthrough and is a good
thing it has to be arranged but the
range and within their range what Basel
does is it to restrict determine which
is exactly the kind of right so
graduated responses that you want to
have is sort of to kind of stop capital
from leaking out which we unfortunately
allowed it to happen through the crisis
and and then maintain the leverage that
regulators have which is the equity
issuance and equity payouts in
particular to transition all you need to
say and then you can't even tell me
about issuance cost is retained earnings
now in other words allowing banks to pay
dividends was extremely offensive to
some of us that's it you can see the
paper and some other writings
in this website and we had copies of
some things out there and I guess we
will answer questions I'm the last two
but any one of us will answer questions
if they are any there is not much could
you elaborate on the point of not of
having a ratio that's completely risk
insensitive because I see a problem both
ways but also one was risk insensitive
and it led to regulatory arbitrage
because if a bank was told it has told
the same capital for a loan to a
triple-a firm as to a non-investment
grade firm it led to all sorts of
consequences but if you but the converse
is if you do have risk sensitivity your
argument would seem to imply it doesn't
matter if risk measures are wrong
because bank should be indifferent to
how much capital they hold and that
seems very paradoxical not banks but
society societies banks would we not
like it so but I'm talking about
regulators the vision that we have this
the the vision that we describe is
certainly you're completely right I mean
Kara does not mean anything except for
the riskiness if you have a tall
Treasuries in yours in your assets and
my cap requirements are not they don't
need to be high so clearly it has to be
a function of their with the image that
we have on capital requirements is that
of a marginal permanent exchange we have
in mind these smart regulators instead
of what what the Irwin wants them to do
which is to know when that point is when
a complicated bank is insolvent and just
be there overnight to transform its
balance sheet or when 15 banks are doing
that we want the regulators in healthy
time to to monitor just like an exchange
does for margin calls and to hold their
hands on levers to monitor the systemic
risks more than even individual risk
because maybe some firm through the
allowed to fade and then and adjust the
cap requirements to the risk so when
when I say
percent I mean like for example relative
to current assets I don't know we have
to work on it so I don't know but I or
why am I here you know your turn so so
I'm JP Morgan bank our size if we were
to follow your prescription round
numbers here we would have to raise
three hundred and fifty billion dollars
assuming is that equity okay so yes so
so what I my first question I have to my
first question is will you come back to
New York with me and work on the press
release so they booked the meeting with
my chairman to say that he should issues
over time yes I predict that meeting I
should have paid the dividend that's
what are the first thing okay I predict
the meeting wouldn't go to - well I'm a
second second question - what why not go
to a hundred percent I'm not sure I got
I should we go all the way to her I said
I'm gonna leave all these deposits there
I am leaving the function of banking I
just don't want I want to back up then
have liabilities because liability is
part of their business so Apple doesn't
have that as part of their business but
banks do I want to back up their
liabilities more than is backed up by
now that that's what I want I think some
of the backing some of the liabilities
are not essential to their to their
business long-term debt is not essential
to banking business nobody's going to
tell me why they need long-term that is
we're not advocating a hundred percent
equity clearly clearly that's pushing in
the direction of reductio ad absurdum
what we're doing is we're starting right
now and we're saying if and it's really
what David Miles said and we're backing
it up by just some clear-headed thinking
about it in the sense of if we push
equity more and it may take you a little
bit of time to get to three hundred
billion more neck what do you understand
that but if you if you push that funny
mark one thing you can do is not said
it's not pay dividends for a while but
if you if you if you
basically push more and have a bigger
equity cushion as Peters explained
that's not going to change your cost of
funding you may believe that it's only
going to change your cost of the funding
to the extent that it takes away tax
advantages which we really should work
to neutralize and I realize a lot of us
would like to just say we can't fit it
with the tax code the tax code is what
it is but that's that's too easy in
other words if we're really creating
problems because we're unwilling to
change the tax code that's a real
problem
so let's basically take away the
subsidies take away the tax code push it
in the direction of having self
insurance by people out there that
should be self insuring you and me not
through the tax system but through
holding equity in banks and go to a very
comfortable point where we know that
we've got enough to basically survive
the type of thing that we saw in
2007-2008 your bank did better than
others so maybe it's unfair that you're
coming under this but we know that some
other banks didn't do that well and we
have to make make it safe for the entire
sector and as a first order of that
having a lot more equity not going a
hundred percent but getting maybe 10 or
15 more percent is going to be a huge
benefit and the costs are just private
costs and we should figure out how to
basically take those away so that the
right decisions get made on an economic
basis
right so Paul I think was in one of your
slides that maybe was it it talked about
kind of manipulation opportunities with
Wilson's solution and in Wilson when you
were talking I kept thinking I'm trying
to think in my mind what's the
transition between debt holders and
equity holders because you probably are
going to have a transition right and and
I think there's something that's
important about both of these there's
friction in each one right there's also
a lot of friction and what you're
proposing I think probably more okay
could the two of you just comment on
that friction concept I think I think
our position is is that we don't see
what these frictions are in terms of
true economic cost again there there's
they're private issues here that a lot
of people in this room focus on but
remove those and think about what the
true social costs are and those aren't
salient I think our reservation about
any system that requires some individual
with some discretion in a position of
distress to pull some traders that's
that's something that makes you wonder
why you're having to do that why not
just have that as equity and in the
first place that in particular applies
to the Cocos so it may be good to have a
lot of equity and then in addition have
bail in but again if if you're having
liabilities out there that are going to
provide that bail and there's still the
question what are they what are they
serving why can't they be equity I think
that's the question and they're not
cheaper that's the point they're not
cheaper there's the illusion of them
being cheaper because you say I'm only
paying 6% on this and my equity is
costing me 15 so we know that that's not
going to be correct yeah what led me to
the friction just to clarify is partly
when you put up the thing about the
REITs and then 30% I happen to know a
fair amount about that market and how it
got the way it is and you know I think
it's largely a function of the way
analysts look at things and I think
analysts have a way of looking at things
today well you know the south side in
the buy side and in the business of
making that transaction that transition
is the friction
I think that's associated with
your kind of concept now the friction in
Wilson's is quite different it's
literally a movement in money between a
class of owners that won't be able to
continue holding something because their
own capital requirements will go up so
you have to move the money over to a
different set of buyers right and so I
just wanted to hear about how that would
work and particularly also I didn't
understand Wilson to have a notion of a
trigger that had to be pulled it just
happens yes oh we didn't get into this
the exact issues of triggers there's
been a lot of discussion this I think
the easiest one for me is when a bank is
either critically under capitalized or
correctly illiquid and that can be in a
baling system late it can be in Lehman
Friday when they tell you we can't
settle trades on Monday that does not
require a lot of discretion that
requires knowledge of a fact of deep
illiquidity in a lot of the systems we
use with the FDIC we can move a little
bit earlier than that so there are
triggers that sometimes happen in
advance of that but it still should be a
very late in the game debt like event
okay but but that happens already with
respect to FDIC institutions and I think
the bond market is getting comfortable
saying this is what default or
insolvency means for a bank you could
move that further back if you didn't
have FDIC funds at risk to something
where you couldn't fund on Monday to
answer your more general question at
least as I see it I'm not a not an
economist like the three people up here
the transition from where we are to a
balanced system relies on the capital
structure of banking as it largely
exists today I think that makes things a
lot simpler
I think the there will be transitional
costs but I think they're much easier to
manage some increase in debt cost but I
think that's a reasonable price worth
paying we get too big to fail out I
think some of the cost proposed in this
system would be potentially much larger
I know that you just tell me the cost of
withholding equity payout
that nobody has been able to give me in
a clock well I I can give you one
example when when we issued our Coco's
which are which have to turn inequity on
either a Capitol trigger a failure
trigger or government assistance trigger
so in any one of the bad states the one
they have to become equity so they are
not in any way protected by the state
issuing that debt raise the value of our
equity by about ten percent over the
course of that next week relative to
people saying I thought credit Swiss
might have to retain all of this equity
over the knee over the next period that
this was something that the market
seemed to value this is this package of
instruments better than just write your
triggers that we would need to discuss
this later but the fact of the matter is
that there is if the total risk is borne
by the balance sheet then we have
fundamental insights if the risk cannot
be held by somebody else and therefore
the overall cost cannot change that's a
physical reality of this and this is
like a gravity force okay just the thing
in terms of triggers in terms of
triggers I think that one of the
frictions is is captured by the
statement that I was proved in a recent
paper or by an author that actually was
invited to be here today and couldn't
that shows that there is extremely it
there's a knife edge case where if you
have a price trigger price equity
trigger there's even exist sort of a
rational way to price these things
because there could be situations where
if you didn't have the trigger and they
couldn't in the conversion rate you're
just right you know they would either be
a situation where if you assume that it
converts a dozen and if it's there's
sort of multiple equilibria or one or
North Korea or all kinds of things like
that the trigger based on book values is
not clearly going to prevent a crisis
and so we will debate some today to to
more about these triggers our point
potentially our point completely is that
we have not been given a reason by Irwin
or anybody that whatever he was going to
issue is Coco's should not be equity
just because you can actually sell
something does not prove anything
because you can sell any security up
there McCoy
my final question about Coco's is if
they're so good why don't firms just
issue them firms in the rest of the
economy in other words they're not
illegal to issue there are lots of
things that can be issued if they do
something like get tax benefits and
remove and reduce bankruptcy costs why
don't we see Coco's issues in the rest
of the economy here they're issued
because of capital they because they
have Swiss capital requirements allow
half of the cap program is to be
satisfied this way so there are there
there instead of equity they're issued
but why aren't the issues why aren't the
issues where the rest of the market the
rest of the market can use chapter
Elevens hey go buy why are you sorry I'm
sorry
arrrg why our patients understand that I
understand why people don't focus on the
regulation but you don't have to do what
anything look no back of the car
but even lower with focus why not cause
you get why not Pappas instead of a
couple having spent some time with
leveraged finance people you get very
cocoa like effects with regular debt
structures and industrial corporations
you don't get that for financials so we
have a lot of this automatic
equalization in a normal industrial
company that doesn't happen naturally
for banks we need to do something
different because it I don't want to but
I'm saying that they will feel
differently about it both of our
regulars make them anything but already
highly catalyst anyway sorry one last
question so first first a comment it's
it's interesting I guess that I noticed
her two themes in the in the discussion
one is that the externalities of bank
failure are huge and so there's huge and
imperfections in the asset market which
caught which are arise when bank fails
banks fail at the same time you have
modigliani-miller that requires very
very good capital markets and very wise
investors to perfectly see through that
the risk of their
their holdings has fallen in a certain
way and so it's interesting to me you
have you have both of those concepts
going at the same time just a comment I
guess my second question my question is
is this why didn't the banking sector
work better in the 1800's capital
requirements were at 30% higher mcc's
but capital was 30% 40% it was in the UK
was in the u.s. people still made lots
of bad decisions right there were still
railroad bubbles canal bubbles this that
etc you had you know lots of of economic
history written on this period and the
sort of bad and follies of banking why
did that happen
I'm actually not a historian of banks I
barely didn't know anything about bang I
know enough to ask this question from a
year-and-a-half of looking at it but the
history of a bank I don't protect to
know but I can say the following they're
these banks were not publicly held the
access to equity could have been lost
they had they they didn't have
diversification opportunities like banks
they have it the world is different the
question is why can't the world be the
same on the total capitalization that's
the question it affords our banks right
now why not so we can go back in history
and ask these questions and we can come
up with all kinds of reasons they might
or might not have to do with where we
are right now so we're asking you right
now but the banking system that we have
right now and given the crisis that we
had just recently why can't we what is
the impediment for thanks to stop paying
dividends and equity payouts and raise
some right offerings and other things
and capitalize themselves over the next
five years six years to levels that seem
crazy but maybe or not when a not said
that she was going to be on the stage
until someone took her off I was
thinking myself gosh is that going to be
me
actually the last 10 minutes or so even
though we went over with them i i've
you'd is actually quite memorable and I
wouldn't have missed it for anything I
want to thank everybody the speakers the
participants the clearing house Paul for
a wonderful day and I learned a lot and
I hope we get to do this again thank you
for coming